Jennifer Nelson has been a storyboard
artists head of story and director of
animation for over 20 years she's best
known for her work directing Kung Fu
Panda 2 & 3 currently she is working on
her first live-action feature for Fox
the darkest minds presenting the award
to kristin rockin maker is Jennifer
Nelson
[Applause]
I've been asked as all of us have why
there are so few women in certain
creative positions in our industry the
jobs of writers and directors with a job
is to make a mess rather than to clean
it up to throw the room in the creative
chaos challenge and disturb with
inspiring adrenaline is often filled
with men studies suggests and I'm
presenting a gross gendered
generalization here but I apologize
because it does apply to me so I can you
know say it does that when faced with an
unfamiliar task women are less likely
than men to just assume without evidence
that they can do it
women want proof before risking their
likelihoods Vasari before risking their
livelihoods and those of everyone
working with them there of course many
reasons for this but I don't think it's
necessarily a bad thing if you applied
that same caution to piloting a plane
I prefer flying with the pilot that
knows pretty damn well that they can do
it when I first read last days in winter
I was struck by how dimensional it was
it was gritty messy disturbing and
inspired it offered a character who was
a woman who was tough and flawed but was
also still a woman
it was also just flat-out entertaining
we aren't told when reading these
scripts anything about the author we
don't even get a name so I was very
surprised and deeply touched when I
learned these authors story
Kristen Rock maker has been a producer
in unscripted documentary television but
her true passion was to be a writer she
had stopped being a writer she said
because after a run of read and
rejection cycles self-doubt had crept in
here I was reading a script that was
tight and it may never have happened if
that doubt had grown roots the world
needs more fresh voices like Kristen's
it needs strong and different points of
view and
characters as fascinating as January it
can be a lonely room we live in as a
woman director or writer it's not
surprising we may need a little bit
extra encouragement it falls on all of
us to see and acknowledge those trying
to do those tasks those who need to have
proof that they can do it so Kristen
Rock maker we're here tonight to add to
your proof to say that you are very
talented writer and to welcome you up as
one of this year's Nichols fellows
[Applause]
okay thank you
Thanks I'll try not that they thank you
quite so much as I did in my my video
but thank you Jen that was um really
amazing you made me sound so good you
made me want to hang out with me haha
that's not easy to do you guys were so
good those scene has been in my head for
so long so to see it come to life is
just amazing and even better than I
could have imagined so thank you
I want to thank everybody who came out
I'm from New Jersey so some people were
local some people came from afar and it
really means so much to me to have the
support so thank you
and I thank my mom who has encouraged my
writing since I was a kid and who was
home in New Jersey with my children who
I am sure are stuffing their face with
Halloween candy since mom and dad aren't
there I want to thank my husband who has
supported me for many years in big ways
and small ways including making sure he
was home for Halloween the other day
while I was here and then hopping on a
plane the next morning to come out and
support me so thank you Morris I love
you and lastly I want to thank the
Academy it feels really nice to say that
but no I really do because I feel like
confidence is something that you really
need to succeed in this industry and I
feel like it's something that many women
struggle with including myself and even
when I was writing this script you know
it's um that's a tough story it's a
woman who is strong but she's
complicated and she's flawed and it
deals with some difficult issues that
were grappling with now in our country
so I'm writing it and I'm like man this
is probably never gonna get off my
laptop you know it's probably not gonna
see the light of day so for it to win
the nickel and for like important people
with good taste to say like yeah we like
your character and you know your story
resonates and we like you and we want to
hear more from you
I mean it's just so gratifying and it
means so much and it really gives
much-needed confidence so thank you so
much
[Applause]